[Applause]
did joe buddy release another podcast
besides the one that i listened to yo
i listened to a 30-minute clip that he
posted that says what happened with
spotify on his youtube
which has far less subscribers than my
youtube but let's not because
let's not compare let's not compare guys
let's not compare let's not compare
listen
very successful in his own right my son
very successful
right no my son is very successful he's
all right you know i can help him out
with this youtube game if he wants but
it's all good it's all good
so and and i thought al
i thought that i was being incredibly
fair i
complimented him i complimented his uh
listen ability i complement his ability
to garner an audience and i con
complemented the connectivity that he
has with his fans my criticism came
from a fundamental lack of understanding
of
corporate dynamics and how they do try
to own you
i thought we articulated that where's
the push back out
because everybody in the comments were
like y'all didn't listen to [ __ ] and so
many people said that i was like
maybe we listen to everything bro what i
heard is there's a video clip that my
homies checked out when
they were talking to me about it and he
left out like for example the watch
thing i brought up
somebody was like i can't believe
spotify tried that watch [ __ ] i was like
he wanted a watch and they were like
whoa really i didn't hear that in the
clip i listened to where is it
i had to go find it in the audio that he
said hey i'll take this watch and then
they said no
because my point was like all right if
you're upset at the watch just say no to
the watch if it's that offensive and
they're like yo that
he never said yes to it he said no to it
and i was like we listen to different
clips
because the original podcast when he
first talked about it
he spoke on it for a really long time
more than half hour yes it was about an
hour
well i that's on him for just saying
yeah
he released a half hour clip of it so
maybe that's why you
maybe that's where our disconnect is
maybe some things were left out of that
clip
for example me saying oh you're gonna
offer me a rolex okay i'll take a rolex
and then they still said no but and this
also might be you know when you have
very very strong
fans of a person and whenever someone
speaks
out against that person they just say oh
you're dumb for
not agreeing with whatever my fandom let
me tell you something i realized
joe budden clearly is a lot more popular
than we realized because our comments
are wildly negative on this one i tried
to tell you
no and i said it i think in the piece
like he's he's garnered
intense fans which is amazing and that's
credit to him
i just from what i read in the clip that
he and i read listen to in the crypt but
he posted
i didn't see i saw a fundamental lack of
understanding of how
corporations operate that's just what i
saw
now his criticism of corporations is
accurate
and i i
now understand i didn't understand this
prior but not because of joe button
because of something else but i now
understand why you often hear
the slave analogy used
when it comes to like athletes and like
the owners of the teams
like they go now realizing that well
here's the thing i never realized it
before for this reason i was like
well you can't be a slave if you're
getting paid millions of dollars and you
wanted to do it
and you want to do it and it's your
choice right and i always thought that
was like insulting to what slaves went
through
why would you compare you know what
you're doing playing a sport you can pay
millions of dollars compared to like
these people who are like forced into
servitude for their entire life and like
those things are fundamentally different
here
is the connectivity being
owned they do own you that's what i was
going to say they do own you
you are a you're it's a they pay a lot
to own you
and the money goes to you but they own
you they own you
and that lack of freedom when we equate
what do we think of with slavery lack of
freedom yeah so that
lack of freedom we jump to slavery now
when we think about slavery we go
black people getting whipped and you
know forced to do these horrible tasks
etc that's way different than a sport
but the idea of corporations this goes
back to our conversation about like
trying to like
carve out the moats so they don't have
to innovate the idea behind these corn
corporations is i want to own you and
carve out the moat so he trapped in that
[ __ ] house trapped in that house
you're trapped in that castle
i want to own beautiful castle beautiful
caves ain't going nowhere nowhere
better like the view that's what it is
so the the you got so excited to go onto
the island you realize they put up that
drawbridge and they stuck you in their
mother
stuck so here's the thing i understand
now we're coming from i think the word
slave should never be used
just because in the same way that i
think the word like privilege should
never be used like
white privilege just don't use the word
like it's not a privilege they don't get
shot by the cops
that's what it should be so stop talking
about
what should be normal for black people
as a privilege
because then nobody will be on your side
to support it
if you go yo i want normal then white
people will go
well yeah y'all deserve normal yeah but
when you tell people they're privileged
everybody got [ __ ] in their life they
don't like
dad's dying cancer you gonna tell me i'm
privileged or something like that not me
personally but like then white people
like we'll [ __ ] you for that
it shouldn't be a privilege but it
should be bare minimum we should all be
bare minimum yeah but that's why we say
why privilege because we don't even get
he's just talking from a marketing
aspect
if you're trying to get we understand
you're right he's just saying marketing
wise when you say that to white people
who are struggling
they hear their privilege like no i'm
not privileged and then they push back
whereas there might be more if you're
just like yo we don't get basic human
rights
they'd be like oh that's [ __ ] up you
only get i get basic human rights my
life sucks
but i get basic human rights that sucks
y'all don't get that like that's just
what i'm saying like it's it's a
privilege
compared to what you're experiencing
yeah but
i would argue what you're experiencing
is should not be the normal
it should not be what you're promised by
the constitution
you're underprivileged yeah you need to
boost that up to regular
yeah and don't get me wrong there are
people who have privilege
billionaires kids me you know what i
mean i'm six too i have both my parents
like these things you could argue are
privileged
100 but my guess my point is like that
little marketing thing i wish we could
switch like i wish i could like sit down
with like blm or
all these people like the left and just
like yo get that out of here
stop talking about like that because i
really do believe there are like a lot
of decent
white people out there it's like yo i
don't want people to get less than the
constitutional rights they deserve like
let's [ __ ]
yeah we're talking about it a lot of
people are already angry with how their
lives are
and if you're telling them they're
privileged that angry part of them is
like
[ __ ] you on privilege what are you
talking about very good at communicating
so that was brilliant that's exactly
what i'm trying to say yeah they're just
angry and then if they they feel like
their life sucks and if you tell them
they're privileged
that part of them is angry and insecure
it's like [ __ ] you i'm not privileged
i got this this and this if you're like
yo we don't get basic human rights
they'd be like oh my life sucks but
yeah i don't get basic human rights [ __ ]
yeah yeah
anyway so back to the corporate thing so
you they want to own you man
and it's like let's take away the word
slavery but talk about being owned you
don't have the freedom to operate
as you want to operate yeah i
understand it now and i understand it
even if you're an athlete that's getting
paid 30 million dollars a year
but you're making that company a billion
dollars a year
and you don't have the freedom to go
make up that other [ __ ] you feel owned
if you're an ncaa athlete right
you don't have the fruit now you do but
before you didn't have the freedom to
make money off your likeness but they
can make billions of dollars off of you
i can understand how you feel owned yes
you're signing up to be owned
to that point joe said his smallest
check was spotify so you're feeling like
i'm making you billions you're paying me
less than everybody else
i make you the most emotionally [ __ ] you
you owe me i'm trapped here i want to go
go
i felt go go i would say that's
if he had known that going in he might
be more okay with it all right
spotify gonna pimp me but i'ma pimp them
as hard as i can until this contract is
up and then it's done yeah and i felt
bad when i was looking at the comments i
was like yo we're pretty nuance him
and when we talk about things like we
actually read and we actually watch the
videos
unless we're doing feelings no facts
like and something like this is it's
important because it affects us all
and economists were so [ __ ] up and i
was like well man maybe we fundamentally
misunderstood
you know what joe was trying to say or
maybe we didn't read or like listen to
or watch something that he was trying to
say maybe we got this wrong
and then i heard from a grapevine that
joe
asked spotify for 250 million dollars
what yes wait
wait this is a reliable grape
this is this is a reliable grapevine
that he asked spotify
for 250 million dollars
so everybody in the comments shut the
[ __ ] up
this goofy out here talking about 250
million dollars
250 million dollars yo that business has
a k
education he was talking about he's
getting you need to keep educating buddy
250 million wait what they wouldn't even
give you a [ __ ]
rolex submariner you want 250 million
though the line of thinking is i i'll
probably i outperform all the ringer
podcasts this is what they got i should
get that
i don't even think he's comparing
himself to rogan i think he get wrong so
either
and i don't think that's actually if i
pull back i can kind of see what he's
thinking
i blow all these podcasts i can't say
it's a fact
this is a legend you know what i mean
now
usually that's not that's enough
information for the media to run wild
i gotta hear how he came to this numbers
i think it's the ringer
i think it's the ringer ringer was 250
million it comes with a bunch of shows
well yeah you see the list like how that
girl did dr dre's
ex-wife
[Laughter]
joe got dr dre's ex-wife's lawyer
yo what's more ludicrous dr dre's
ex-wife she sounds mad
reasonable after charles asked me 250
million dollars right
10 times at least she was married to the
man
oh my god wow 250 million bro
i think that's more than rogan got you
got to be crazy to ask for that
i think that's more than rogan got
so this is what we were talking about
about not truly
understanding how corporations operate
and the dynamics within a corporation
and that was my criticism
in that video and thank you so much
joseph button
for um making me right
i appreciate it i think that's all is
there anything else
i guess my only thing is i not even joe
budden whoever's listening
the only thing i want the fans who will
like listen to us who get it is when you
sign a contract
know as much as you can about this deal
when you go into it and then do
everything you can on the front end
to get what you can out of them and if
that don't work for you
start a patreon yeah because look
watch 50 million dollars i want i want
the camera on black alex right now
i really can't understand 250 million is
crazy now
i i will say this i applaud
anyone that is creating leverage
on an independent platform that's joe
budden
that's us that's joe rogan
and creating enough leverage where
those contracts that they sign with
mainstream
media because we should be able to
operate with mainstream media we should
be able to blend we should just do it in
a way that's fair for us
right i applaud them that are trying to
create those contracts
where they are less owned where there is
more freedom to operate and you earn
that freedom
by creating the leverage yourself joe
button's best shot
at 250 million is go independent your
next the next time somebody tries to buy
you out that [ __ ] is going to be a lot
of money
because he's going to create something
independently that works and when it
works somebody wants to buy you and
and then own your 500 all right now you
have to pay them could start a patreon
and probably make more money
than they were making or at least the
same amount of money they were making at
spotify i bet you
i think they have a devout fan base and
i think that they could do well on
patreon
because people are already willing to
pay for spotify but i do applaud anybody
that's trying to do it because
everything that i've done in my stand-up
career
has been outside for the purposes of my
own success
the reason i share it with other comics
is because i want to create
a situation where they can have
independence
and leverage and then use that leverage
to get
very fair contracts with
mainstream media because we shouldn't
have to fight mainstream media
the ideal situation is that we work
together
but we bring people they bring people
and if we're both bringing people
we both got to get paid and we both got
to have freedom yeah
you know what i commend them even though
i do think the number's a little
ridiculous
i commend them for ha
like that feeling of value and saying
hey if
i if you guys don't give me what i think
i'm worth
i'm out of here so i commend them for
that because it also
sets the benchmark for everybody who
comes after you
yep so now it's like it adds a little
value to
let's say hip hop or music podcast where
it's like yo
look at what i did and now you can value
yourself within that
range you create your own values yes
someone else validates so i'll give him
that
but whoa i need to see how he came to
that no that's absurd 250 million is
absolutely absurd
maybe it was 250 million for all the
podcasts that would operate under him
maybe the 360 for him and everybody on
everybody else is that the other but
it's still an absurd amount of money
like
you just don't have enough eyeballs for
it um
but look man you know you can have the
biggest patreon in the world
i'm curious to know those those numbers
do that go
try it anyway we love y'all
we appreciate y'all um thank you guys
for listening
we do have a patreon episode happens to
be the biggest comedy patreon in the
world no big deal
no i mean not a big deal only the
biggest one
in our field of interest that's just
what we do that's how we do it
that's just no big
you